so today we're going to be talking about
an approach to writing apps that work on
both your web browser and work in your
mobile apps and so maybe a better and
shorter name for this talk is probably
just how we do cross-platform so this
topic comes up a lot when I talk to
people who write JavaScript that react
native conferences after all our web
apps are written in JavaScript and our
react native apps are written in
JavaScript so of course it's natural
that we want to share some code why
can't we so I'm going to talk today
about some things that we've tried
things that we didn't do and things
where we landed on how we build
cross-platform components Squarespace so
I'm a team lead at Squarespace on the
mobile content editing team this is a
really cool photo of our mobile team in
cupcake formation because cupcakes are
amazing and this is me staring directly
into the Sun during the last solar
eclipse wearing last year's chain react
t-shirt I was wearing the safety glasses
so up until a couple years ago I was
writing nothing but native apps I was
writing iOS apps in Swift and an
objective-c and even before that before
there were even iPhones I was writing
straight C and C++ and I know a lot of
you guys out there probably JavaScript
developers who know react really well
and want to know want to use your skills
and react to write some really cool
mobile apps but I'm completely different
I'm a mobile developer and I'm looking
at react native from a rep from a native
developers perspective and so while
javascript is a language that I've
always had experience with it was still
kind of a leap to go from being a native
developer to learning Bonnard JavaScript
learning react learning react native but
it all worked out so I get to work with
a lot of other teams who are building
really cool stuff in JavaScript this is
a this a web app for editing your
website built by our CMS team this is an
engine for editing your website adding
blocks to a page customizing its content
and it's really just beautiful and so
this team shares a lot of common
missions with my team their mission is
to build to
and stems to interact with your content
on the web and my team's mission is to
build tools so that you can interact
with your content from a mobile phone
another team that I get to work with
that writes a lot of really great
JavaScript is called forms and fields
these guys pioneered a lot of the work
about sharing code between web and
mobile and they probably understand all
the nuances between iOS and Android and
development probably more than anyone in
our company and so this is our mobile
family portrait we've got a pretty big
array of apps that are really focused
and serve distinct purposes for our
users
and on my team the mobile content
editing team we're responsible for
building experiences so you can work
with your content on your phone our
mission is to enable you to create
access and change your content wherever
you are when you're on the go and I'm
lucky enough to work pretty diverse
array a diverse talented team of Android
iOS and JavaScript engineers and it's
our goal to build our next generation of
apps sharing as much code as we can with
our web team instead of making 3
separate implementations what we'd love
to do is share code so even before there
was react native we were building apps
that shared node modules between our web
and our mobile apps what you're seeing
here is a blog post editor we can add an
image we can rearrange content and this
is a hybrid app this app juez has native
code it has JavaScript code that's
running in a web view the JavaScript
lives in a webview and communicates with
the native laver layer over a
well-defined bridge this should seem
familiar if you guys have played with
any react native before which I hope you
have so this talk is in three parts the
first part is an architectural talk
we're gonna cover some choices that you
have and we'll talk about the choices
that we landed on next we're going to
talk about JavaScript we're going to
build a sample component together that's
cross-platform for web and mobile and
then finally we're going to talk native
and we're going to talk about how you
integrate your components with a native
app
so right at three times let's talk about
how we used to have to write these apps
so this is just how you used to have to
do it you'd write your app one time in
JavaScript for the web you'd write it
another time and maybe Kotlin for
Android and then one more time for good
luck you'd write it in Swift and you
know it's so inefficient to write our
apps three times we wind up with three
different sets of code bases three sets
of implementations and let's face it we
have three different sets of bugs so
what did we do to address this so let's
let's first look at something we all
know what happens if you do react native
an it for a new awesome project you've
all done this a million times and you
hit NPM in spa so the first thing of
course is you get your node modules
folder has all of your dependencies in
it has your applications dependencies
and most importantly it has react and it
has react native modules in it next you
have your native classes these you can
choose to never touch except maybe the
link may be a native module if you have
to but if you're like us you might
choose to expand out this native layer
and build yourself a hybrid app and then
finally we have the components of your
app this is where your app declaration
lives and this is where your platform
specific components for your react
native app lives we all know this and if
you did a good job you start off your
packager you fire up Xcode you run your
app and you get our familiar welcome
screen so now let's compare that with
what happens when you create a new react
j/s web app so we do a similar thing we
do create react app another awesome
project we npm install and once again we
have our node modules folder we have our
react module instead of a native app on
top now we have the bones of a web app
this is where all of your platform
specific web and components are going to
live and so that we fire up our server
we open our web we will open up our web
browser and we see that our app is
running and we're really happy so but
when we compare the our
texture of our react native app with the
architecture of our react.js web app we
see that at the application layer we
have two different sets of
implementations on two different
platforms and so it's our first impulse
to want to merge these together into a
single cross-platform module wouldn't it
be great if we only had to write our
components one time and we deploy
everywhere and it looks exactly the same
on every platform we could even power it
with using one of those platform
normalization layers we know them react
native web there's react native
primitives and this creates that common
component language for all of our
platforms but this didn't work for us
writing it one time really didn't work
our design goals were not to have a
consistent UI across all platforms we
wanted to have experiences that were
special for each platform we wanted
something special on mobile we wanted
something special on the web we also
wanted to build it using tools and
methods that we already knew we wanted
to be able to use CSS for the web we
wanted to be able to use our react
native controls on mobile but we still
wanted to be able to share code between
these platforms so what did we do we
took another approach our approach to
extract out the shared business logic
into its own layer into a shared layer
component this is where all of the
shared logic that doesn't evolve UI is
going to live on top of that we build
platform specific components on top of
it this lets us build code in an
uncompromising way we can use the tools
that were already familiar with and this
lets us go on to compose more complex
cross-platform components by combining
these platform specific components
together so now we can create these
really rich and complex components that
look great on any platform but the
business logic only needs to be written
once so this is the link picker
component we built it for the web and it
looks amazing but this is the same
component on mobile and what's great
is it looks and feels amazing on mobile
as well but it has distinct mobile
experience it still shares a large
amount of code with the web component
cousin there's a lot of business logic
going on here
we're hitting endpoints we're parsing
JSON we're turning it into model objects
and building a hierarchy and we're
maintaining all this state and what's
great in was the own we only need to
tackle this problem one time and then on
each platform we can worry about how to
present it to the user in a platform
specific way so we're not really writing
it three times anymore but we're
certainly not writing it one time either
so I guess you could say it's safe to
say we're writing it about one and a
half times and what I mean is you can
share about 70% of your code between
platforms and the remaining 30% is what
we rewrite on each platform in a
platform specific way and this 30%
consists mainly of UI rendering code and
some component interaction code and
that's a lot better than the 0% we were
doing before and this still lets you do
things the right way for the right
platform so let's take a quick look at
how we organize our code to do this so
this is a basic folder structure of one
of our modules you see there's a shared
folder there's a react native folder a
web folder and a package.json at the
root the package.json at the root is
used to declare global dependencies and
it's also used to have some helpful run
scripts that we use for watching and
building and initializing the shared
folder contains our shared business
logic this is the basis that we build
all of our platform specific components
on top of and the web and react native
folders contain a platform specific
components these are composed from the
shared components and from other
platform specific components to build
new and warm rich components each folder
has its own package.json with their own
platform specific dependency
declarations so that's our folder
structure now let's talk about how we're
configuring babel to let these folders
work together so
here's an example of our dot babble RC
file for our react native target and
what you can see is that we define a
target alias that points at our react
native folder for the web we do the
exact same thing we have a target alias
but this time it points at our web
folder so now our shared code can import
a thing from a target and depending on
what target you're compiling for you'll
get the right thing
so let's make this real let's build a
component together this is the
JavaScript section of our talk so let's
build a component that accepts keyboard
input and as you type it formats it as a
telephone number first we're going to
start with the base shared
implementation we're going to make a new
file we're going to call it tel num
input J s and we're going to put it in
our shared folder and this new component
is just going to extend the basic
component so now we have an interesting
import already we see that we're
importing from the Nova remember this is
our shared cross-platform layer but
we're importing a platform specific
thing using our target alias so it's
case we're importing a number loader it
has to be loaded somewhat different on
the web versus react native what's cool
is we can just use this target alias and
it knows to do the right thing and so
now we're going to implement some
functions this is again in our shared
implementation we have a component we'll
mount we're gonna make an instance of
that thing that we just imported then
we'll make a helper function this helper
function is going to be called from our
platform specific components in this
case this is a format function it
returns back a formatted version of the
text that you typed as a telephone
number and so that's it for our shared
business logic this is a simple example
of course so now it's time to make our
react native implementation of our tell
num input component so this time we're
gonna make a file it's going to live in
our react native folder and we're gonna
call it the same thing
tell num input j/s we're going to call
the class the same thing it's called
tell num input and extends basic
component but what's cool is these two
imports so the first import import is
importing from our shared library this
is all the business logic the second
import is a platform-specific string
input field that we've already created
this and it
already exists and so we're pulling in
things from both places the
implementation of our mobile tell num
input field is made up of only a single
render function and that's great if
that's the only thing that's different
between our web and our react native
implementation that means we did a good
job of separating our business logic
within our render function the first
thing we do is we call that format
function that lives in our shared
business logic and because this is
shared business logic it'll work the
same regardless of which platform that
it's running on and finally we return
the string input field but it's
configured specifically for mobile so
you'll see there's a few props here auto
capitalized autocorrect keyboard type
and these are specific to mobile and
what's interesting is that only this
platform specific implementation needs
to know about these properties and so
here's our component running in a
storybook and I'm just typing and it's
formatting as I type and it's doing the
right thing just as we expected this is
a this is storybook so now let's do the
same thing for our web component this
time we're going to make a ton of input
component it's going to be in our web
folder it's going to have the same file
name it's going to have the same class
name and the good news is that it's
almost identical to the same class that
we made for react native you'll even
notice that as we make our new tell'em
input in our web folder that the imports
the imports and the class declarations
are pretty much exactly the same and now
in our web-based version of the
component the whole implementation again
is just our render function we call our
the first thing we do is we call our
base class implementation format and
it's going to have the same business
logic regardless for on the web or if
we're on react native and this time
returning a string field that is
configured using properties specific to
the web platform we have a class name we
have HTML attributes and we have a type
and again this is only in this platform
specific implementation of this field
and so here's the web version of our 10
ohm input running in a storybook
you can see the formatting logic works
exactly the same as we type just as we
expected but the styling and the
configuration is specific for the web so
once we've built a bunch of components
and they're all working cross-platform
we can just publish them internally as a
node module and have them used by all of
our apps and if we're building a purely
Greenfield react native application and
all of your application code is going to
be in JavaScript then we already have
everything that we need to start our app
we can continue by adding just
JavaScript components or app without
worrying much about the native app maybe
you might have to link in a native
module here or there but that's all you
really need to do but if you're like my
team then you may also be developing
code on the native side there are some
experiences that are just a lot easier
to do on the native side there's also
some libraries that we already have that
live in native such as our networking
our persistence library and frankly
we've built up libraries over years that
we just want to leverage and use in our
app but the great thing about react
native is we can choose to go native
when we want to or stay and react when
we want to so this is an example of a
hybrid app but if you're building a
hybrid app or even if you're building a
mostly JavaScript app that has a little
bit of native code in it then your work
is not done yet right after you've done
publishing your component library you
still need a way for your react
components to play nicely with native so
next I'll talk about some strategies and
code to help with this native
integration and what we're showing here
is that our react components need some
kind of native representation that
native representation is usually a
native view that wraps all the
boilerplate of react native and abstract
the component as if they were just any
other native view there's generally two
ways of doing this that I've seen and
they're both pretty similar the first
one I kind of call a mono wrapper I
think this is what a lot of people do
this wraps everything into a single
dependency this contains all the native
code from the modules that we import the
includes react native itself it includes
any other dependencies who have that or
native that come along with it it would
all the applications and p.m.
dependencies this would also include
your cross-platform component library
and would also wrap all of your
applications components and what's great
about this is that you can just do this
one link dependency between your app and
your app doesn't have to know really
anything about react native at all the
dependency module exposes a native
wrapper that contains view controllers
for your high-level features and
integrates nicely into your app and this
approach is probably great for most
teams who are building hybrid apps but
we had to take a slightly different
approach with our apps we wanted to
build a module library we wanted to be
able to individually select components
that we wanted and we want to share this
module library across different apps
this allowed us to keep our bundle sizes
small and allowed us to share these
components across multiple apps but in
order to do this that means that your
app has to have some more reactive
native knowledge you have to define a
package.json you need to create your app
j/s and you need to import and register
the components that you want to use so
there's a little more knowledge that's
going to be in your app but what you get
is you get to pick exactly what you need
inside of your app and we built the
components of our app into their own
module and then we import these
components into our app we do this as a
separate module so the application logic
can work in both our Android and our iOS
apps we also built a react native
toolkit that contains a small library of
native helper classes for wrapping react
native components in native view
controller classes
it helps us reduce a lot of the
boilerplate we have with using react
native and really importantly it helps
with methods for facilitating
communication between the react lair and
our native layer so this is generally
how we layout one of these components
that have a native wrapper around it so
at the root of the module folder you'll
find the JavaScript implementation for
your component and our index j/s so that
it can be imported and then what you'll
all
so C is platform-specific folder so
we'll have an Android folder and iOS
folder and in these platform-specific
folders will have one wrapper that is
used so it can be used inside of native
so now let's take a look at one of the
implementations of these wrapper that
uses our react native toolkit so first
we make a new class that extends the
base react view controller this react
view controller of course is part of our
react native toolkit and the classic the
class itself that react view controller
extends a native view controller so that
it can play nicely with your native app
so there's minimally only two things
that you need to override you need to
provide to this the name of the
component that you want to bring to life
and you need to give it the props that
your component is going to want when you
create it another super helpful utility
is our react bridge that provides a
singleton react native bridge for your
app so if a bridge instance is not
explicitly given to one of your
components will use this shared instance
and that's good because you'd be sure
that your bundle is only loaded once if
you have multiple instance of your
component on the screen it's same at the
same time and you could be sure that
there's only going to be a single
JavaScript context running so another
thing that the react view controller
does for us is it helps for routing
function calls from JavaScript up to a
specific instance of one of your wrapped
react components so let's see why this
might be challenging so in this case we
have two instances of the same component
that might exist at the same time in
your app and each of the components has
a react view controller wrapper and
we've instantiate these components from
the native side and so normally whenever
you want react to talk to the native
side you have to create yourself a
native module manager and that provides
the interface that react uses to call up
but now I'm going to read a couple of
lines from the react native
documentation about native module
documentation I'll do this really quick
so native modules are objective-c
classes they actually can be Swift also
that are available in Jas and typically
one instance of each module is creative
per Jas bridge and the fact that native
modules are Singleton's limits the
Meccan
in context of embedding and that said we
would need to keep a mapping from
identifiers to native views in the
module so this is done for a good reason
but it does complicate our
implementation when we're doing
embedding we have more than one instance
of this component on a screen at a time
so what the documentation is saying is
that when you make a function call up
from native there's only this one
singleton instance of your manager
and it's up to you to figure out how to
route these function calls to which
instance that it needs to go to the
documentation is suggesting that you
make a map and for every instance that
you create you put it into the map the
key the map can be any unique value that
you want we use a UUID it could be the
tag ID of your root view controller and
we call this key a reference and this
reference is passed down into the
component when we create it and so once
it's passed down into the component when
we need to make it call up we just so
this is an example of calling up into
native we just passed that reference
back when we make the call we're of
course leaving out the well we'll get
onto this so actually so what's
interesting is you need to actually
declare this twice you need to declare
it once in your native module manager
and then you need to declare it again in
your component that actually does the
work so this is an example of how you
would do that mapping if you had to
write it all by hand yourself when
you're embedding components the only
purpose of this native module manager is
to route the call to the right instance
that you want to use so the first thing
that that this function does is it looks
up the instance in our reference map
using that reference and once we have
the object we can call a function that
we really wanted we can pass all the
arguments that we've received and we can
just leave out that first reference
parameter and so here's the
implementation in our wrapper that's
doing the real thing on the native side
in this case it's just saying hello so
this is like the round trip going from
well not the route this is the whole
trip calling from react up into native
to do a thing so that's a lot of
boilerplate we recognize this and the
purpose of the wrapper is to take care
of a lot of that for us
so one of the nice things about this
wrapper what it does for us is it
handles that reference mapping for us
automatically so inside of the wrappers
implementation is this function called
props with reference and its job is to
grab the props that we declared in our
component and then using a helper called
object reference we create that
reference string given that instance and
then we insert this reference into the
actual props that we're gonna send to
our component and so now when we create
I'm react native view you'll see that
we're passing the component name that we
originally created in our component and
we're passing this props with reference
function that has the injected reference
ID inside of it I should point out that
even though this is Swift code we do the
exact same thing on Swift and on Android
in a Kotlin so a few slides back I
showed how you had to actually declare
your native functions twice so we
created a little helpful macro that
reduces some of that boilerplate called
a callback method this implementation
does the work of looking up the object
the map it does the job of copying all
the incoming arguments to the outgoing
function call and it does that all
automatically for you so the first
argument to the macro is the signature
that you're exposing to react this is
the function that you actually call
you'll see that the first argument is
that reference argument and then
anything else are all of the user
arguments that you need to pass into
your function the second argument is the
datatype of the wrapper that you have
and the third argument is the signature
of that function inside of your wrapper
class and so when you declare this macro
inside of a natal native module
declaration it will create all the
functions for you automatically all you
need to do is focus on the
implementation of what you need to do
when react is asking native to do a
thing so we've covered a lot we've
talked about architecture and why we
chose to go with our particular
implementation of one and a half times
the main takeaway here is that
by breaking out code into a shared
business module you're free to develop
UI code that's specific for the platform
that you need in the way that you want
to we built a cross-platform component
together and saw it running in the
browser and a mobile app the main
takeaway here is that you know you've
done a good job if the code separation
when you only need to write the UI code
and finally we've talked about native
integration and showed our react native
toolkit that makes integration easier
and the main way here is that your work
is not done
you've got your component and it's
important to think about how these
components are to play nicely with your
native app well that's it this is my red
screen of thank you hopefully I didn't
trigger anybody
[Applause]